now it's not only truck drivers who are
in short supply many businesses are
suffering from a major shortage of
workers a record-breaking 4.3 million
americans quit in august that's the
highest number ever recorded and with
the 10.4 million jobs open employers are
scrambling to find help cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger joins
us right now jill the supply chain
issues are causing major headaches for
consumers how long is this going to last
well i think unfortunately these
logistical log jams shortage of base
materials and goods it's going to
persist and definitely through the
holiday season probably well into 2022
according to the economist that i've
been talking to so also probably going
to see higher prices persist right
through the beginning of next year
probably through the end of the first
quarter can we talk about this great
resignation being called why are so many
people walking away from good paying
jobs are they just unhappy with their
jobs i think what has happened in the
last 19 months has done something
seismic to the labor force one economist
said to me it is as if all of us went
into a 19-month meditation about our
lives our families and our work this is
causing change changes up and down the
income stream low pay workers may say
i'm not going to take that bad job with
no benefits in erratic hours some of the
frontline workers completely burnt out
they may retire early go a different
direction there are also those folks who
are basically saying i learned a lot
about myself my family i want a better
work-life balance and i've got to figure
out how to do that what's really clear
to me is this will persist and it is
something that is staying in this labor
force for a while i'm hearing about this
more and more people doing a lot of
self-reflection about what really
matters to them what should people do
but if they're thinking about quitting
their job what should they do what
should they know well if you have your
health coverage through your employer
which you know more than 150 million
americans do you should book those md
appointments get that stuff scheduled
and do it but while you're at it before
you leave why not look at what you have
in terms of benefits explore your health
care coverage what would you do if you
lost that coverage should you go on the
affordable care act it's a lot more
affordable through the end of next year
because of stimulus measures should you
go on cobra it can be really expensive
the next level look at your life your
disability insurance coverage can you
take it with you your retirement plan
don't just blow out of that retirement
plan and take the money there's a huge
tax event when you do that and i think
what's very important if you're
considering leaving stockpile some cash
and the reason is you don't know how
long you're going to be out of them out
of the marketplace i don't want you to
stay out too long because you can get
rusty skills but cash is really going to
help you get through any transition i
always say cash is king but i keep
hearing employees have the leverage here
because
companies have seen people want to work
the hybrid model do they have the
leverage that it that we keep hearing
that they do the model has flipped
dramatically and i'm going to tell you
something this is the time to figure out
what is important to you is it pay if
it's pay go do research see what's out
there go back to your boss say i want a
higher salary if that boss is not
willing to pay you more maybe a one-time
bonus maybe extra vacation maybe
benefits if you want flexibility go for
it right now tell your boss i was
productive i can be productive i've
proven it and get the deal that you want
right now the time is not this is highly
motivational i want you going in there
can you take the meetings from yeah well
i'll be talking to your agent
you also have to know how much the
company is making yeah well you've got
to know if the company is in a place to
be able to give that to you and if not
maybe it is time to leave yeah and watch
out for those tax events my least
favorite events tax events jill thank
you very much